a manhunt is underway for two accused
murderers who escaped from a central
California jail Santos Samuel Fonseca
and Jonathan Salazar broke free
yesterday from the Monterey County Jail
both face murder charges in separate
cases
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside the jail
in Salinas Jonathan what do we know good
morning to you Anthony this jail holds
around 800 inmates this morning the hunt
continues for two of them the Monterey
County Sheriff's Department is leading
that investigation at this point it's
still unclear how they managed to escape
both of them have been inside since 2018
they are considered incredibly dangerous
the alarm was first raised yesterday
morning when both inmates failed to show
up for roll call their inmate clothing
was actually found outside of this
facility at this point it's also still
unclear if they were acting together or
alone Fonseca is 21 years old he's
accused of killing two people in 2018
Salazar is 20 years old he is charged
with the murder of one person in 2017
both men were set to appear before a
judge early next year this is not the
first time that someone has managed to
escape from this jail five years ago and
they may actually managed to call
through a ventilation duct
he was later captured police are asking
anyone if they do manage to see these
two missing inmates to keep their
distance and to call 911
gaile all right Jonathan thank you very
much